Once you've taken a giant leap forward for mankind...
...and the novelty of walking on the moon wears off, what's there left to do?
For Neil Armstrong, the shortlist evidently included bacon.
Popsci's Vintage Space blog this week suggested that...
...the first meal eaten on the moon included dried bacon squares,...
...a space snack so popular that it apparently originated in the earliest Gemini NASA missions.
Other less salty items on the menu likely included peaches, sugar cookie cubes and coffee.
Although astronauts in space today get comparatively gourmet treats,...
...zero-g menus are conspicuously short on bacon.
As the Smithsonian magazine asked on its website, "Do astronauts not deserve bacon?"